ah I kind of always thought about eBay
as like a fun thing a slightly alcoholic
magical beer the first time Harry liked
drinks in it like warms his whole body
it makes you feel all warm and fuzzy and
said so that makes me think the
butterbeer is damn good
I think Starbucks take on it will be
butterscotchy sugary and there will
probably be some caramel in it like a
Frappuccino and like V creamy I'm just
gonna throw it out there I think maybe
it's gonna taste a little magical
[Music]
Akio butterbeer I mean it smells good I
only smell the kid literally it's not
like a Yankee can oh my god of color um
is interesting cheers Cheers it's a
Starbucks drink that's not bad
it's very sweet it tastes like my first
foray into coffee when I would go to
Starbucks and I'd be like can I get an
iced quad venti 2-putt manila skim
caramel macchiato with extra caramel I'm
a little bit disappointed I'll give to
my child on that birthday in a very
small quantity I really better berry
hold on just like I'm gonna close my
eyes like let's set a harry potter scene
it's cold we're dogs need we've got the
scarfs on it's snowing yeah yeah I can
taste the magic so this one definitely
looks more like butter beer looks like
it'll taste good is it frozen yeah it's
like a little more frothy on top I can't
get anything through the straw this baby
is yeah I like this a lot I guess for
what it is it's pretty good this is a
desert like a dulce de leche ice cream
tastes like childhood this is a drink
that you would definitely get while
you're waiting for my mom to come pick
you up in the movie this is like if
honeydukes sold a butterbeer yeah just
sugar sugar sugar sugar magic
this one is more butter berry than the
other one looks better too I would
definitely drink this if there was a
special Harry Potter event at first I
was like wow it's really sweet and now I
can't stop drinking it the more I drink
it the more I like it
is there crack in this if you like Harry
Potter you should try it yeah like I'll
definitely be telling people that I've
experienced that go get yourself a
butterbeer Frappuccino but be nice to
your Starbucks barista all right guys
thanks I've got to go to divination
nerds were Harry Potter nerds
[Laughter]
[Music]